después de una sangrienta represión que
mató a más de 100 manifestantes
antigolpistas la comunidad internacional
ha rechazado las acciones de la junta de
mianmar jefes militares de una docena de
países incluidos eeuu reino unido
australia y japón condenaron el uso
letal de la violencia en una rara
declaración conjunta un ejército
profesional sigue las normas
internacionales de conducta y es
responsable de proteger no de dañar a
las personas a las que sirven los
embajadores de la unión europea en
mianmar incluidos francia y españa-
también pidieron conjuntamente a la
junta que dimitiera describiendo las
acciones del ejército birmano como
inmorales e indefendibles la onu condenó
igualmente los asesinatos el secretario
de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken denunció la violencia en
su cuenta en twitter estamos
horrorizados por el derramamiento de
sangre perpetrado por las fuerzas de
seguridad birmanas que demuestra que la
junta sacrificar a la vida de la gente
para servir a unos pocos envió mi más
sentido pésame a las familias de las
víctimas el valiente pueblo de mianmar
rechaza el reino de terror de los
militares
el sábado fue el día más sangriento
desde que los militares destituyeron al
gobierno democráticamente electo del
país y entre los muertos había niños el
elevado número de fallecidos se produjo
en una jornada simbólicamente importante
el día anual de las fuerzas armadas que
se celebra con un gran desfile militar
este año asistió el viceministro de
defensa ruso y algunos representantes de
china tanto rusia como china han
bloqueado la condena del golpe de estado
en mianmar en el consejo de seguridad de
la onu hasta ahora más de 400
manifestantes a favor de la democracia
han sido asesinados desde que la junta
militar asumió el poder a principios de
febrero